il y a 6 1 jean sébastien chouinard a
lancé un défi à un ami ne pas boire
d'alcool durant tout le mois de février
depuis que je travaillais en argent je
ne veux pas ça tous les jours
puis c'était le premier moment de ma vie
pendant dix ans je sais ça boit plus que
deux jours aujourd'hui c'est des
milliers de québécois qui relève le défi
à chaque année bonjour mon nom et
amérique orange fait le défi 28 jours
pour la bonne raison de prendre soin de
son corps et de sa santé parce que il ya
quelqu'un de mon entourage qui est aux
prises avec des problèmes de toxicomanie
et problèmes de dépendance depuis déjà
25 ans et les objectifs liés à la santé
et à la forme à marseille
l'argent recueilli jusqu'à maintenant
par les participants a permis cette
année à la fondation jean lapointe
d'amasser plus de 220 mille dollars pour
6 soutenir la fondation jean lapointe
pour les aider à faire la prévention
auprès des jeunes
mais au delà de la cause quand on boit
une quinzaine de verres par semaine
comme jean-sébastien est ce facile de
relever le défi de la sobriété
le plus difficile c'est le fameux verre
de vin du vendredi par ce qu'elle
perçoit 1 terminée c'est la routine de
chaque de plusieurs personnes
le sam soit jeu c'était vraiment ces
deux périodes charnières c'est qu'est ce
que je fais pour me détendre en fin de
journée je pense qu'après trois jours je
sentais que je te dire plus plus vivant
puis reposer mais j'avais les merlus au
maire nous avons demandé au docteur
j'ignore quel genre d'impact 28 jours de
sobriété pouvait avoir sur la santé
d'une personne qui consomme
régulièrement l'alcool quand on en boit
quand on en voit surtout de façon
excessive et transformé dans le foie
gras
puis ce sera là et au long terme ce qui
peut faire c'est s'accumuler s'accumuler
et favoriser la présence de cicatrices
dame fois je croyais beaucoup de
cicatrices dans le x ça peut mener à la
cirrhose
après un mois d'arrêter de prendre
l'alcool on a vu qu'il y avait une
diminution du gras dans le foie il ya
une
l'innovation de la tension artérielle et
une diminution du poids donc oui il ya
certains bénéfices et a arrêté de boire
pendant un mois
mais ce qu'on sait pas si ses bénéfices
là sont bons à long terme
évidemment les effets positifs vont
s'estomper ici on recommence à trop
boire une fois le défi terminée
lorsqu'on a le goût de bourg après
étrangement non on n'a pas le goût de
bois tout dans mon cas moi
personnellement c'est prêter ou la
première bière est vraiment satisfaisant
mais on dirait qu'on n'a pas encore on
reprend pas la route selon plusieurs
participants à ce genre de défi affirme
moins boire après avoir passé les 28
jours de sobriété rien de cause à effet
que les scientifiques n'ont toutefois
pas encore démontré ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal